dead city is going to pick up a couple
years after we La last saw the gang with
The Walking Dead well it's a new series
for
find someone and it didn't go well now
I'm trying to get out of it the walking
dead stars Jeffrey Dean Morgan Lauren
Cohen and Norman Reedus updating fans on
the series newest spin-offs it's kind of
a reset for me everything kind of
breathes in a romantic way we have the
backdrop of France Norman makes his
return to the franchise this time in The
Walking Dead Daryl Dixon we have the
catacombs the Eiffel Tower the you know
is
like the whole vibe has different super
romantic it has a very uh
artistic look to it uh the tone is
different the music is different a lot
of it's in French it's all French people
uh
it's just it's completely different and
a lot of the story is me trying to
figure out what's happening and how to
get out of here and if we're gonna have
a fight if we're getting a lot you know
like there's a lot going on but it's
it's super poetic it's super beautiful
it's uh
it's not a repeat of the same show at
all
meanwhile Jeffrey and Lauren have their
own spin-off The Walking Dead dead City
Maggie tracks Negan down she needs his
help at least that's the story she's
given him we're starting off with Maggie
Negan in a new Terrain in New York and
uh
Adventure Beverly is a little bit
misleading I think New York City as the
backdrop in this world is is going to be
really special we actually get to shoot
the show largely in New York City and
that's huge for us as Carriage is huge
for us it's a show and people are so
used to seeing the walking dead in
Georgia and now we're in New York City
in some amazing locations and
um and a really intense emotional story
so all the things you come to The
Walking Dead Universe for with a
slightly different lens
and now the pair says fans are in for a
ride I don't think they're going to be
disappointed I think they're going to be
really happy and I think you know
there's a lot of speculation what's this
relationship between Maggie and Negan
and it is not they're not getting
married you know what I mean yeah I'll
give that away
um it's tenuous at best it's a they're
they're needing each other for a very
specific reason I think that the hope
with this show is to introduce introduce
you to the place our characters are in
and why and then just let you go on a
journey because I think everybody can
relate to grief to deep resentment hate
trauma the rage that can overwhelm you
in life and the desire to move through
it and that's just a piece of what we
get to delve into in this concentrated
story Negan has gone back probably a few
steps in that Redemption Arc out of
necessity in his survival instincts so
you know it's going to be a it's going
to be a rough road but
going down Fifth Avenue is not that bad
of a road to go down
[Music]